foreign
and you're pushing
hmm
do you unsure of what to uh what you're
feeling for that's why you try different
feelings
your right hand shook too did you feel
it yes
and you're in her shoulders so she's
pushing into your shoulders per
prescription
and you did it right back to her that
that is the ego tripartite
still in her shoulders
she she is shoving you can see she has a
linear line into my shoulders so that
energy goes down
my hands don't
safe so they don't have to get tension
could you you you're now being
contagion by my relaxation
do you understand but your prescription
is not to relax okay so as you feel as
you feel my tension go away in my body
you don't let that happen to you per
prescription Okay so
no matter what then don't aim that into
her shoulders
goes down into her Center you see that
little
China thing
so I'm right there you're in your Center
not up here
you pay attention because because she's
pushing her her core will lock on her
okay but if I push at the top of this it
kind of just tilts her
you see well once I go into her Center
you'll see that the pelvis kind of cage
like that you see that the case like
that and if you can't see it you can get
closer over here maybe even this angle
you can see their Bells
for development
so here she's locked because that's what
happens when you try to be strong if I
just push the top on this lever it just
tilts her
but I want to go into that center right
there
there so here it is from the angle you
see it kind of turns straight in
from the angle trying to use
so that that'll always happen
as I do this row
even when it looks like I'm
I'm going in her shoulder you should
always there it is right there
it is right there so for me it's like I
didn't did it did it
did it did it undid it did it this is
just arm wrestling
and because that's my only goal
it doesn't matter what I do with my arms
do you see
so I don't have to do the keyhole
do you understand
but if I was to do the kihon it's the
same way into this thing
into the set not out it's called
not up top
does that make sense
right okay
Let's uh
aim differently
okay
so again
to do a drill
you have to follow the prescriptions
just like if I'm going to do bench press
my bar is prescribed not to bend or
break the barbell do you see
oh if I start doing something outside
the prescription I can't do the drill
then I cannot get the desired effect
from Drilling
okay now there's all kinds of things
because in the nageuka relationship
the uke is also working on something
okay not they're not a a passive
receiver that this this is not correct
okay they're going to receive the energy
the young energy of nage
and they're going to reconcile that
energy through the same internal process
that Naga first reconciled the
prescribed young energy that uke was
doing
but what happens is out of the ego
tripartite
and
it's fuel or it's it's being fueled by
fear is once the uke feels a any sort of
transition from the initial Yong
prescription they now will subvert the
drill as they do something else okay so
the most obvious one is a beginner that
uh will stop pushing because they
realize holy cow I'm adding inertial
momentum to the projection do you see
okay
uh this one is very subtle but it is
there okay so you do the initial Yong
push but as soon as you feel
your Center you just you you stop you
start yielding do you understand
um
and that's creating a false success
okay
so
and again this is why you need a teacher
because that looks that looks
close didn't it you're making his Center
move I see that but a teacher can tell
that from the way your whole body was
organized that
you you wouldn't even have the ability
to project that that Center that he took
away the prescribed young energy
remember how Virginia remained locked
do you think she hence when I pushed on
her shoulders she just tilted see
um had she not remained locked when you
push on my shoulders right her knees
would have stayed down
so what happens is you go as as I feel
you trying to get in my Center then I
disengage the center you see that so the
teacher could say that this posture
and the vectors that she attempted to go
into your Center
uh are not truly viable
so if I just continue the prescription
instead of when I feel her
do you see a virus continue the
prescription
so none of this is going in the ground
so
you were going to prolong it okay I'm
I'm just matching your young energy okay
just stay here
what is happening
but you're not going okay what else do
you feel in your body uh tension in my
arm s okay okay do you feel I'm just
matching your energy
do you feel the fatigue setting yes do
you see so we stay here forever I'm
going to be here for forever so I just
have the IP adhesion but you're
basically doing
deltoid bicep and you see that you're
going into a fatigue State I see that
you're gonna get burnt out pretty soon
do you see
some areas
okay
whereas if we do it the other way and
you're pushing
keep pushing
I'll put my arms Wherever You Are
[Music]
I have some weird mechanical
disadvantage
there's that fatigue did you feel it yes
I'll just keep matching you
there it is you see your weakening your
fatiguing because it's in your arms
do you think you got you petered out
okay so
for her to get a reasonable feedback on
what you're actually doing
you have to keep your prescription so I
I don't do anything as you can except
the prescription until
this is all shoulder you see yes okay
so maybe try try the external deep
leveraging and same thing I don't go
ah Tokyo take your candy I keep the
prescription when you see that's arm y
watch watch me go as a UK
ah Coke you home do you see okay so it
said it's a prescription and you can now
you can feel oh I am in my deltoid
and this arm has gone this pretty much
like
from 0 to 1 10 and 10 is maximum power
this arm is floating around
0.5.1 you see it went dead you see that
yes you get that so there's barely
anything on it
okay because this Drew all your
attention
so as opposed to if you keep pushing
again like you're going to fatigue your
arms then I can do much stuff
whereas watch
if you as you feel me get into your
Center you see I want you to now
disengage from the prescription right
when you feel that
okay now this is not trained
do you understand
so she pushes the whole time
pushes the whole time
never taking care of yourself so usually
you the the the UK will go ah poke you
hole because they're afraid to fall but
you're only you're not gonna fall hard
okay so the whole time
you push you push
far away all that is frighteness you're
gonna push
better
no there's no need to touch on the
ground because you're not falling hard
good
you you win a little
right there that's you disengage you see
so that's just stay there in that
disengaged State hey you got it that's
why I couldn't hear me
so I'll we'll get there cosmetically
okay let's go this way for the cat Okay
so yes you're gonna do it externally
okay wait I want to get in that
teeter-totter position so you're pushing
don't push past me till I get there
don't push past me till I get there just
don't collapse here
but don't shove into positives stay
right there I I know I'm gonna get in
that position you were you see
try lady me in
do you think yes I did
I just don't forget now watch
you get to me in that precarious
position and you feel that yes now step
in you see oh
Okay so
first of all people that are doing
asocial violence they don't they don't
do that self-protection thing
okay
but we're now not doing the drill
when we get false positives
okay that's why you need the teacher but
the weak Link in the system is you have
to do what the teacher says even against
your instincts
your instincts are fear-based at this
point do you understand
okay
do that same side I'll be over here
look did you see your right hand travel
towards her so I want you to to
demonstrate what I am trying to key in
on your it's in your right hand you're
going to tell me what's my point
externally
holding up
no
what happened is this had moved towards
her and her Center didn't move oh okay
do you see that which means you're
external you're not in her Center do you
see that flip-floppy yes okay
we just do this so you see this this
part can you see that
so
this has to
uh stay here but go there
you understand so I you were first in
the before we filmed you were materially
conceiving that you push here
scene but you have stopped the
prescription you're no longer engaged in
pushing do you see that okay so if you
keep that pushing and I do what you did
you'll be able to push my hand down if
you see
okay whereas if I keep the extension
and
you push down push down push down don't
disengage
yeah
push down
do you see now watch your body
so you your hand
was not able to get that Yin space which
it would always be able to do if I'm
just moving
your wrist you see that
so same thing happens here
even though I'm here I don't go
okay
it goes in your I'm in your bum so for
example I'll take you this way
bring me back
and not here
or in this connection point
in your body
here
the disengation stay at your wrist you
can shut down
shut down all you want
look at your second
okay you can do it you're shoving down
and you can do any
you can go the other way see your elbow
you're gonna take away all the chemical
dancing if you pay attention I do you
feel this way now so instead of leaving
this up
just flip
so flip
for sure
this angle should be more impossible
you see but no it's in your butt
[Music]
so if you're doing the kihon
once you got here what you're doing in
the keyhon is it it integrates the
external you see so you cannot push as
hard you see that
as opposed to your hair
you can push pretty dang hard right you
understand
so I combined
and integrate the external like put you
at a more mechanical disadvantage but I
don't want to go
external external
when you integrate
not here
leave it take some energy off but here
we're in that same
in your body not in your arms when when
I'm in your arms you're in my arms
see and that's by shut down when you
want
okay